US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has
accused several countries including
Russia of spreading false information
about the pandemic an issue of
disinformation is there any particular
locus for this disinformation ours of
diffuse it's pretty diffused
unfortunately but we've certainly seen
it come from places like China and
Russia and Iran where there are
coordinated efforts to disparage what
America is doing in an activity to to do
all the things that President Trump has
set in motion here well accusations
against Russia over disinformation and
takes about the coronavirus president
Europe and the whole world are a big
design firm ation and fake themselves
let's take a look at the presumption of
innocence if there are accusations you
need evidence with no evidence there can
be any claims moreover it can be used as
a part of such an aggressive
informational campaign earlier Donald
Trump placed the blame for the spread of
coronavirus at China's store alleging
that the situation would now be better
if he'd known about the virus earlier
the president added that the world was
paying a very big price for Beijing's
supposed it in action
Pompeyo joined in the blame game
accusing China of putting lives at risk
a Chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
took to Twitter to lash out at those
accusations demanding Pompeo stop lying
she noted China's efforts had actually
saved lives citing the World Health
Organization anti-war activists ken
stone thinks Washington's accusations
follow a long-running pattern of blaming
others for their mistakes wow the whole
world's been looking at with that
admiration at the way socialist
countries such as China and Cuba have
handled this pandemic though the US
administration has been exposed
completely as inept in dealing with the
corona virus Trump has discovered that
the easiest most least controversial way
to deal with a problem in the u.s. is
simply to blame it on Russia or China
you